hey everyone thanks for having me super
excited to be here open sourced probably
one of the greatest macro trends of our
time right
I mean people working together all
around the globe on a voluntary basis
this efficiently at this scale that's
that's pretty awesome my morning routine
these days is just read the news get
depressed log into github get hopeful
about humanity again thank God for open
source and thank God for all the people
behind open source and that's you
my name is Austin Collins and I'm
looking for the clicker there we go
I'm the creator of an open-source
project called the service framework
it's pretty popular right we just hit
25,000 stars on github we have a
fantastic community a really
enthusiastic community of supporters
contributing to it they contribute to I
think they've been about 90% of all the
contributions the open-source community
has over the last year so it's a
self-sustaining project and it's picking
up a lot of momentum I'm also the
founder of a company called serverless
Inc and we make great tools for building
and operating service architectures and
yes today I'm going to talk about server
list stuff but I'm gonna do it in a
different way because I don't think many
people really understand what's going on
here and if you agree with this
assessment I'm also gonna suggest a new
opportunity for the open source
community in this surplice era so here
we go it appears that we are using more
externally managed services in our
applications than ever before that is
you are using more services that you
don't own and operate and that your
company doesn't own and operate in your
applications than ever before and yes
we're still making our own services so
we're gonna do this for a long time
we're still going to make our big custom
monolithic services were to continue to
make our small micro services and we're
probably gonna continue to have
religious arguments as to whether or not
this one's too big and that was too
small that's going to continue however
it appears that we're using more
external services in our applications
and further it appears like we're using
a lot these days
runtime services ton of growth here
lifecycle management services a lot of
growth here office services community
services customer services the
goes on and on you can call these cloud
you can call these SAS you can call
these server lists whatever you don't
own and operate these someone else does
and that's an important distinction and
it appears that we're increasingly okay
with using all these things at last
year's open source summit Jim showed a
chart suggesting that a lot of the code
in our applications these days is
written by other people and that's right
it's the open source community is
writing a lot of our code these days
because we're all using so many open
source services at libraries and
frameworks and our applications but
perhaps we can make one minor
improvement to this I think that a lot
of the code in our applications these
days is yes absolutely open source but
it's also a lot of external services
right and these things are taking up the
majority of our application logic and as
a result we're writing less and less and
now these external services are taking
up more of our application logic than
ever before and as a result it seems
like the custom code we need to write is
much less than before and if that's true
it also seems like maintaining the
machines and the environments necessary
to run our custom code isn't that big of
a deal as it used to be instead what
makes more sense these days is solving
business problems writing code running
that code went on whenever it's needed
and only being charged for whenever it's
run and wouldn't it be great if there
was an externally managed service that
provided this to that service computing
so ladies and gentlemen I present to you
the service architecture many call it
the service pole architecture and I'm
introducing it in this manner because
whenever there's a server list talk
people always focus on the compute part
this whole functions as a service idea
and that's very powerful but the compute
is only one part of what's happening
here the service architecture is not
just about these functions but it's
about using all the azza services
together
AWS lamda without AWS s3 aww slammin
without dynamodb aw salmon without API
gateway not as valuable because you
can't do as much stuff serverless
compute needs server list services
service computer is probably going to
pave the way for more of these services
in the future and together they're
really valuable and together this is
really what this
this movement is all about when we built
the service framework we had this
philosophy in mind the service framework
has three simple concepts it has
functions events and resources resources
is where you put your server lists
services like your AWS s3 bucket or your
DynamoDB table events is data coming
from those service services that trigger
your functions which contain your custom
code now this may not be what we thought
the future of applications was going to
look like but a lot of people like this
and it's a very simple way to think
about these new server lists service
full architectures now why is this
happening why are there more external
services these days well I think first
off it's because we want to build fast
and/or build more and we want to manage
less right I mean when the boss comes in
and goes okay we need to solve these
three problems and if we do so we're
gonna change the world as an engineer I
respond I'm in that sounds awesome
right that sounds fantastic but then
what happens right after that is the
boss says great but before you do that
could you please maintain everything
we've already built and then as an
engineer I say oh oh my god really
and that just you know takes the takes
the excitement out of it but also why
more external services because the world
is moving faster than ever and if you
want a snowball's chance to keep up let
alone lead in a world where the pace of
innovation is one of the most important
things building and maintaining
everything yourself it's just gonna be a
hard way to do that it's not very
competitive and now no doubt when you
give up control well you give up control
to an external service there's a lot of
devastating downsides potentially you're
talking about costs we're talking about
reliability we're talking about locking
we're talking about legal we're talking
about your data and there's these are
plenty of strong reasons to continue
building stuff for yourself I'm not
saying that there's anything wrong with
that absolutely not and thanks to
organizations like the Linux Foundation
thanks to organizations like the CN CF
and thanks to the open source community
it's getting much easier to build and
maintain things yourself however it
appears that the culture is signaling
that may be building and maintaining
everything ourselves is just not as a
try
have anymore and this is what the
service movement is telling us and
honestly when you need to go somewhere
do you first build a car anyway the rise
of externally managed services has
caused the rise of this notion of the
service architecture service
architectures won't take over everything
it's early days for service
architectures but it's likely that
they're going to grow and to get really
meta what if the rise of the service
architecture just results in more
externally managed services right how
many of you are already offering a
service that's relying on somebody
else's externally managed service AWS
they just build all their new services
on top of their old services and that's
a big reason why they move so fast and
perhaps who knows three years from now
all the stuff I showed earlier perhaps
your stuff your stack could include
twice as many services in the future I
don't know it seems like it could be
likely just given history in there and
the trends we're seeing right now now
some of this makes sense to you why does
it matter like what does it really mean
for all of us well I think for
developers it means opportunity oh my
god these service services are the
greatest building blocks of all time it
is a terrific time to be a developer the
service era is the golden era of
software development we could finally we
could finally build more manage less and
it's getting easier right you don't need
to go be a specialist anymore you could
be a great generalist and the diversity
of the things that every single person
here can make is going to greatly
increase and perhaps it's plausible
who knows that maybe one day developers
in every school and every startup and in
every enterprise organization will reach
for the service architecture as their
go-to
general all-purpose tool before anything
else because if you want to get
something done and you want to get
something done with really really low
overhead service architecture is
becoming the new best option for doing
that now for vendors I think this also
means tremendous opportunity not only is
there a lot more demand for service
services but we're talking about
building building kind of provisioning
updating distributed systems that are
largely owned by someone else right
we're building them on top of other
people's stuff that's a really hard
problem like how do we build test
provision update observe distribute
systems that we barely own and deliver
them in a reliable performant way that's
a tough one that's a problem that we
want to solve over at serverless Inc but
a lot of opportunity there and then
lastly for the open source community
what is the server list mean well I
think I think that again tremendous
opportunity I think the service movement
first off doesn't want to focus on
infrastructure they care about outcomes
they don't want to think about databases
they don't want to think about load
balancers they don't to think about API
gateways they want to think about
software features we're moving way up
the stack now and I think stitching
together managed services with custom
logic to make serverless features that
could be reused by anyone is a huge
opportunity for open source an ecosystem
of open source server 'less features
that derive insights from an image
respond to a delinquent payment send a
confirmation email respond to a slack
command update a user profile detect
sentiment in your comments send a
reminder text message respond to a voice
command I think now managed services
will take on a lot of that stuff and
help with those features but the open
source community in particular has a lot
of opportunity to create a rich vibrant
ecosystem of all these turnkey solutions
that anyone can install right away in a
month we're gonna announce service
framework version two and this project
has again one one simple big goal and
that's to better enable you to package
up external services with custom logic
and events to deliver reusable service
features and applications and the goal
is to create a system where you could
easily bring in these features all built
on service services to rapidly build
your applications and applications that
have remarkably low overhead so if this
sounds interesting to you just check us
out at service comm we're going to talk
about it a lot up in the next month and
to wrap up I like to offer one last
consideration I started talking about
how the service movement is about
managed services and how it's about
outcomes and today it is but I think
tomorrow the logical outcome of all this
stuff I think the service movement this
goal is to abstract the complexity out
of software development
till it's accessible to everyone I think
this is the most meaningful impact that
the movement can make and we must keep
this in mind as it progresses we must
ask hey do we want another generation of
people who are forced to care about
patching provisioning upgrading scaling
infrastructure in order to deliver
software or do we want another
generation of biologists writers
accountants who could all build their
own software to solve problems and make
an impact in their specific field
I think the metric of success for
service is not going to be to increase
the quantity and diversity of software
that we can build but to increase the
quantity and diversity of people making
software and that's it check us out if
you're interested service comm and the
framework is open source of course thank
you
[Applause]